welcome back henderson has a new
restaurant boom bang fine food and
cocktails opens this thursday at the
corner of valley verde and the 215 and
here to tell us all about it is the chef
and owner elia abumrad how are you good
how are you i am so happy you're here in
the kitchen with us okay the name of
your restaurant what's the back story on
the name boom bang it's you know it's an
explosion it's a loud sound it's get it
done
and at in the restaurant sometimes you
know we say it like boom bang move it i
need to carry them in the name of the
restaurant yes how would you describe
the menu to someone watching right now
so the menu is um
there's a lot of good technique french
technique that's how i was trained but
it's like
new american food we're like a
neighborhood restaurant but of course we
want everybody from the strip you know
yeah
it's just all every protein is
antibiotic free
like most of them are just
from people that we know you know like
no antibiotics no hormones the best
produce um and most of our stuff is made
in house our bread our tarts let's talk
about some of the stuff you have here
first off what are you gonna make for us
today so we'll start that we'll start
assembling something what do you think
i'm gonna make these uh tomato tarts and
that's when your signature it's one of
our signature dishes yeah through like
through the year we're gonna pull out
like different savory tarts because you
normally see them sweet but we want to
do something with them savory or i i
yeah okay what goes into this so this is
like a puff pastry oregano
sea salt and then this is a fresh
marinara that we make now people are
watching they recognize you from tv
before and your time on top chef as well
is this your first restaurant that
you've opened up no no no i've had a
restaurant before in the sunset strip
right between the whiskey and the go-go
just imagine the crowd what brought you
to las vegas honestly this is the first
place that i came
when i came from france came too so um i
love las vegas i came here with uh joel
robuchon to open his team um see his
restaurant with his team and now my
business partner tony angadi he uh he's
the one that brought us here from france
and now full circle in las vegas we get
it okay we have less than a minute here
i want you to assemble this and also
check out the bread so what's going on
we would like
cut the tomato thinly sliced and you
have all kinds of cocktails you brought
fine wines here at the table yeah and we
have a fish here and pork what do you
have also on the table so yeah so then
you have the tomatoes
yes you set it up then we put some
beautiful olive oil oh
very special very important always stuff
and pepper and yeah you know like we
want to make everything fresh from
scratch as much as possible we are
located on
75 south via verde drive 215 and valley
verdi
i love that you went in the henderson
location so easy to get to off the 250.
so anybody can access you guys and you
can make reservations on open table or
go to our website boombang
dot restaurant and check us out on
instagram and facebook as well you know
you've tried this out just right i gotta
wrap things up and this just looks
delicious yeah thank you so much made
with love oh
congratulations congratulations on the
opening of the restaurant it's right
there boom bang open in henderson on
thursday thank you so much